hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so there's going to be a lot of
speculation in this video because this
really is such a hypothetical
what if jessica had never disobeyed the
benny jesuit sisterhood
now jessica was bred by the sisterhood
and trained by reverend mother gaius
helen mohammed herself she was guys
hello mohammed's best student and the
sisterhood had really high hopes for her
so high in fact that she was tasked with
one of their most important missions she
was supposed to give birth to the mother
of the quizet's hatterac
so when the bini jesuit played their
matchmaking game and made it so that the
duke lato would choose the lady jessica
as his concubine they had given her the
task of only bearing daughters to the
duke later
now what the benny jesuit didn't count
on is that jessica would actually fall
in love with the duke lately and give
him the son that he wanted instead of
the daughter that the benny jesuit had
told her to create
now this of course completely threw off
the benny jesuit plan
jessica trained her son in the benny
jesuit way and he had the powers of
quizzette's hat iraq but without benny
jesuit conditioning per se he had all of
these outside influences
but what if
jessica had obeyed the sisterhood
what if jessica had only given daughters
to the duke later
now i don't have any doubt in my mind
that lato would have accepted the fact
that his daughter was the heir to house
atreides though the dune universe does
have certain feudalistic elements
inheritance isn't patriarchal princess
ireland for instance is heir to the lion
throne of house karina
so jessica's daughter would have been
accepted as the future of house atreides
and probably trained in a similar way as
paul it's also likely that the events in
which led the emperor to
giving house atreides the feet of
arrakis would have still occurred
because nothing about paul being a girl
would have prevented the atreides
soldiers from becoming more and more
skilled or have prevented house atreides
from becoming popular within the
landsarad
so the plot against house atreides might
have still happened
now this is where the benny jesuit
sisterhood come back into the picture
the vinnie jesuit sisterhood had always
intended to marry an atreides daughter
to a harkonnen's son the benny jesuit
have great influence over the great
houses of the lanzerad and they've been
the matchmakers of the imperium for
countless generations i think it's
likely that the benny desert sisterhood
would have stepped in at this point gone
to house atreides and house harkonnen
and suggested a marriage
a marriage between fade ratha of house
herconan and the atreides daughter heir
not only would this be an end to the
feud
also
house harkonnen by marriage would still
eventually inherit arrakis but this
would be after how sarconan would be
inherently changed by the influence of
that a trade he's joining of course and
not to mention the bini jesuit now the
joining of the harkonnen's son to the
eutrades daughter would have resulted
and the quiz that's had iraq and the
difference here would be the benny
jesuit know about this quiz etc they are
perfectly aware of its birth and so they
are able to observe and influence at
every part of the process of this
child's development and we see this
behavior in the benny desert sisterhood
in the later books with uh
special children if they didn't in fact
remove the child from its parents and
raise it themselves under strict bini
jesuit conditioning and training they
would monitor and check up constantly
with all sorts of vinnie jesuit spies
the result theoretically would be
someone who is fully under mini jesuit
control who fully buys into the benny
desert sisterhood and is compelled to do
their bidding as paul never was
now what would happen next relates to
one of the key ways in which the benny
jesuit have always operated and that is
through religious manipulation
now one of the purposes of the
sisterhood's michionara protactiva was
to prepare the human universe for the
coming of the quizats had iraq the
michionera protective was of course the
sisterhood's protocols for religious
seeding
it's how they created legends and myths
on different planets across uh the human
universe it's how they created the myths
and legends about the mahdi and elisan
al-gaib on arrakis to prepare for the
coming of the quiz at tatarak so they
probably would have been very careful in
how they introduced
the quizets hatarat to the human
universe they probably wouldn't have
done it all at once it would have been a
subtle gradual process but one that
ultimately
would have likely played on human
psychology in ways to kind of steer them
away from likely a lot of the fanatical
thinking which led to paul's jihad this
is akin to how in arthur c clark's
childhoods end the overlords the
seemingly benevolent aliens who have
invaded earth reveal themselves at a
time and in a manner that doesn't
freak everyone out and allows people to
kind of accept things a bit easier and i
believe the benny jesuit would have done
things in a similar way so once the quiz
at cataract was revealed to the human
empire he would now be able to look to
the future and look to the past to
determine the best way forward for
humanity to determine the best path for
humanity's comfortable and indefinite
survival and he would use his influence
over the people of the imperium to get
them on board
now
all of this assuming that nothing else
goes wrong in the benny jesuit plan for
one though the michionara protectiva
does work
the benny jesuit don't have total
control of it so it could still get out
of hand and become something fanatical
and also
we have no idea if the benny jesuit
actually could have controlled any quiz
that's cataract
of being powerful enough to look into
the past and look into the future and
become the fulcrum by which the fate of
the human universe turns upon kind of
seems like someone that just kind of
does what he wants to do
the benny desert have an awful lot of
confidence in their conditioning to
think that they'd be able to control
this person especially considering that
their benny jesuit conditioning failed
with the lady jessica leaning to all of
their problems in the first place it is
also likely that a quits at hadarac
would have also recognized the human
potential to invent catastrophe as lato
the second recognized he would have
likely realized the flaw in the benny
jesuit design as lato did and saw the
necessity for a golden path to put a
check on the potential destructive
capabilities of ixian invention i go
into this more on my video on kralizak
so essentially to wrap things up if
jessica had obeyed the sisterhood
it probably would have still gone
wrong for them they likely would not
have been able to control any quiz
that's had iraq and that's ultimately
what the sisterhood realizes later on in
the books
they accept the fact that making a quiz
that's had a rack in the first place was
a mistake
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas peace out
you